Özcan Mutlu ist auf Radtour
durch seinen Wahlkreis.
Er ist Abgeordneter der
Grünen in Berlin.
Erste Station: Bürgersprechstunde im
Freien, Gruppenfoto mit den Helfern.
Das wird umgehend verschickt:
in die sozialen Medien wie Facebook
und in diesem Fall Twitter –
für ihn eine Chance, die Wähler
hierher einzuladen.
Viele Menschen, die in Social Media
unterwegs sind – egal ob auf Facebook,
Instagram oder Twitter – kriegen mit,
was macht der Mann,
und sehen auch, dass ich der
Kandidat, der berührbare bin,
der anfassbare Kandidat bin,
und das ist sehr gut.
Der Grüne mit türkischen Wurzeln
muss online
aber auch viel[e] Beschimpfungen
aushalten:
von rechtsextremen und ausländer-
feindlichen Deutschen zum Beispiel,
die in ihm ein Hassobjekt entdeckt haben.
Was natürlich Social Media bewirkt
hat, ist dieser ganze Hass,
der da in der Bevölkerung früher
anonym war, versteckt war –
der kann viel leichter verbreitet werden.
Mutlu ist Intensiv-Nutzer – seines
Smartphones wie der sozialen Medien.
Also, ich bin jetzt auf’m Weg …
Bis die ersten Nachbarn zum Gespräch
kommen, schiebt er noch einen Termin ein.
Er fährt in einen anderen
Berliner Stadtteil.
Hier geht es vor allem um Integration –
darunter auch Wähler mit türkischen
Wurzeln wie Mutlu selbst.
Und auch die beschimpfen ihn
immer wieder.
„Du Stimmendieb, hoffentlich verfüttern
sie deine Leiche an Hunde.
Komm nie wieder in die Türkei.
Dich werde ich am Montag bei der
Staatsanwaltschaft verklagen,
damit du wenigstens bei deiner Einreise
in die Türkei festgenommen wirst.“
Oder die deutsche Variante des
Hasses, in diesem Fall per Mail.
„Es wird Zeit, dass Auschwitz, Buchenwald
und andere den Betrieb wiederaufnehmen.
Da gehört ihr Dreckstürken nämlich hin.
Ab durch den Schornstein,
ihr Kümmeltürken,
und nebenbei werden sogar noch
Arbeitsplätze für Deutsche geschaffen.“
Da habe ich eine Strafanzeige gestellt und
die Staatsanwaltschaft hat das eingestellt.
Wie Mutlu haben viele Politiker
auch in Gemeinden und Städten
in Deutschland Anzeige erstattet,
weil sie bedroht wurden.
Mindestens einer trat sogar zurück.
Anzeigen scheitern oft auch
am Konzern Facebook,
der die Identitäten der Verfasser
nicht preisgeben will.
Mobbingopfer finden, die Politik müsse
mit einer entsprechenden
Gesetzgebung eingreifen.
Niko Härting kritisiert bisherige
Versuche als zu halbherzig.
Die Politik hat sich … hat sich ganz,
ganz verwaschen eigentlich verhalten,
weil sie einerseits sagte, Facebook
sollte nur Strafbares löschen.
Jetzt wenn Sie aber mal in die
Verurteilungsstatistiken reinschauen –
da wird ja so gut wie nichts verurteilt.
Also ist offensichtlich von dem,
was bei Facebook …
und es wird viel zur Anzeige gebracht,
das steht außer Frage ...
also gibt es offensichtlich gar
nicht so viel Strafbares.
Auch von 40 Strafanzeigen des Abgeordneten
Mutlu war bislang keine erfolgreich,
weitere sind anhängig.
Der Politiker fühlt sich machtlos,
weil die Justiz viele Kommentare als freie
Meinungsäußerung betrachtet – Empörung.
Ich muss als Politiker Beleidigungen
und Bedrohungen nicht aushalten.
Dass ich als Mensch öffentlichen Lebens
natürlich da sehr viel aushalten
muss, das ist mir klar.
Aber wenn ich bedroht werde,
wenn ich beleidigt werde,
wenn meine Familie bedroht wird,
beleidigt wird, dann hört der Spaß auf.
Für Politiker gilt auch das Recht, für
Politiker gilt auch das Strafrecht,
so dass sie geschützt werden müssen,
wenn sie verfolgt und beleidigt werden.
Für Özcan Mutlu liegt es an Facebook,
dass er einerseits solche Botschaften
im Wahlkampf verbreiten kann
und andererseits der Hass
herausgefiltert wird.
Wenn Facebook will, könnten sie auch
Algorithmen in ihr System einbauen,
die Straftatbestände tatsächlich festhalten.
Aber das Unternehmen will das nicht tun.
Mutlu wird sich nun einmal mehr
für verschärfte Gesetze
gegen Hasskommentare einsetzen.
Mit den Drohungen gegen ihn muss
er bis dahin alleine zurechtkommen.